catherine trautmann vrai que l'on a vu
tout à l'heure aux côtés du président de
la république dans des fonctions très
officiel ministre de la culture et de la
communication porte parole du
gouvernement va laisser les clés de la
ville de strasbourg à son premier
adjoint nommé au gouvernement elle était
la première mercredi a annoncé son
intention de respecter la règle de non
cumul des mandats mais ce n'est pas pour
autant qu'elle abandonne le terrain
daniel sportiello et marie emmanuelle
guider l'ont suivi lors de son premier
retour à strasbourg
un comité d'accueil bon enfant pour le
ministre de la culture de retour de
paris
le mari est la fille aînée de catherine
trautmann sens là une réception surprise
en effet le secret avait été bien gardé
et comme paris c'est loin on veut savoir
comment ça s'est passé
et bien justement catherine trautmann a
eu chaud mercredi lors de son premier
compte rendu du conseil des ministres
lorsqu'elle s'est rendue compte qu'elle
avait oublié une partie de ses notes et
ses peintres au but mais il fallait bien
que pour un baptême vivier au moins
quelque chose qui se bat pas exactement
comme il fallait
et comme à strasbourg on n'est pas
toujours objectif quand il s'agit du
maire de l'avis général madame le
ministre c'est quand même bien
débrouillés pour ses premiers pas
on a connu
le sexe masculin toutes ces femmes la
paire ne manque au body ce normal il
était bon et même si après le temps de
l'euphorie viendra celui des difficultés
on aura toujours le temps d'y penser
pour le moment c'est encore l'état de
grâce pour les a pas vus apparaît
alors beaucoup de gens nous en promet
mais je me dis que le pire n'est jamais
certain
le meilleur c'est quand même le petit
déjeuner en famille comme ce matin
lecture du courrier
il est toujours adressé au maire de
strasbourg mais dans un mois 4 entre man
ne le sera plus comme elle l'a annoncé
en raison du non cumul des mandats
certains sont d'accord
d'autres râlent effectivement en disant
mais pourquoi est ce qu'elle nous quitte
et ce qu'elle nous abandonne je réponds
non je ne les abandonne pas et même si
catherine trautmann reste conseillère
municipale de strasbourg déception à moi
je trouve de la chaire à guînes comme ça
c'est pas gentil de sa part
je l'adorais tirez vous c'est cohérent
par rapport à ce qui était annoncé dans
le programme
d'une part et parce que sa ville madame
le ministre ne veut pas l'oublier un
dernier coup d'oeil au dossier de
strasbourg chez son coiffeur habituel